so a major
choice that you have to make in your
life
is what college to go to or should you
go to college and when you go to college
what major should you go to right or
what major should you specialize in
right double majored what uh what's my
minor these are all these are all things
that are important now
uh
these th this article right here that
we're gonna get into from cnbc talks
about the majors that absolutely suck
the most
right oh boy so you know your life
trajectory based on your uh your
decisions that you make can go up down
left right depending on the college and
the major that you choose so let's let's
break down the majors that suck the ones
that leave you
unemployed
and the ones that
equate to the lowest
income not fun anyway here are the least
valuable college majors there's five of
them so bank rate you ever heard a bank
rate no anyway bank rate knows what
they're doing they you know they they so
they're they're a bank
with rates
okay that makes that surprise
no they're
they're a
online media company that they break
down a lot of financial stuff bank rates
um
exactly so they ranked
159 college majors to see which ones
were the worst a couple weeks ago we
covered the best college majors a lot of
engineering stuff going on yeah a lot of
data stuff going on there so we said all
right cool that's great we know what the
best is now go check out that clip if
you haven't seen it just put in
valuetainment economicscast best majors
i'm sure it'll pop up
but what are the worst what are the ones
to avoid so here's how they did it they
said look we're gonna throw in a couple
different factors number one median
annual income number two unemployment
rate and number three the career paths
that you basically don't need more
schooling after you get your bachelor's
degree so with the drum roll please
david let's talk about the bottom
five college majors number five
clinical
psychology clinical psychology the
medial annual median annual income
49 thousand dollars and the unemployment
rate is 3.8 percent all right you're
making about 50 g's a year you're a
little under 4 you're a clinical
psychologist apparently there's not a
great roi
on that
major david for our friends at home what
is roi return on investment that's
something you didn't know in episodes
look at you now bro it's gonna be look
at you my podcast the roi podcast with
david
awesome all right so shout out to you if
you're a clinical psychologist i get it
but maybe there's not big bucks in that
numero
number four
composition and speech what is that oh
teaching people how to
speak better
how to compose their speech that's fine
medial and median annual income why am i
butchering median you need to take that
i need i need a speech therapist there
it is
what are the odds median annual income
forty two thousand dollars unemployment
rate five percent that's pretty high
okay for a college major okay five
percent
um
number three this is why my sister can't
get a job for the last 20 freaking years
since she's graduated college drama and
theater arts oh with espionage oh
thespian are we
oh yes
i see
hamlet
yeah yeah i feel like you've done some
drama in your i've done no drama no but
uh my ex-girlfriend was a theater major
so i know all about that oh yeah i've
seen every musical see how i've had to
sit every single musical my sister's
ever done every dance ensemble every
parody every music act yeah miracon
bailey all that good stuff
oh don't get me started she's still
looking for a joke new world yeah she
went to new world yeah she was a dance
specialist musical theater specialist
with the university of central florida
okay so maybe they were friends no maybe
not probably not yeah my sister can't
keep a friend anyways median annual
income for a drama and theater major 41
000 okay unemployment rate 4.5 okay that
is the third worst college major for
your money
okay damn number two oh my ex isn't
watching this yeah i hope she is
that
you hear that did you hear that woman i
told you
number two
fine arts
the fine arts so being so classical arts
the arts just stay away from the arts
not if you're not if you want a
returning investor from college but i've
got i got an opinion on that that we'll
wait all right go for it
median annual income for someone that is
a fine arts major 38 000 a year no
good after college unemployment rate 5.6
these can't keep a job
can't get a job and get a job yeah fine
arts fine arts and in the
theme of arts oh no let's find the
number one worst
possible major
for roi return on your investment from
going to college here it comes and that
is the visual and performing
arts
yikes median annual income
35 000
unemployment rate 3.6
um what is eve like visual and what
visual and performing arts okay what is
that's kind of like theater no yeah
performing arts that's theater anyway
look if you're in the art world the arts
yeah world the dancing the acting the
singing
there's so many other paths you can take
other than just getting your traditional
college degree i don't know how taking
classes
like the traditional classes because
it's not like you just take art class or
theater class there's other classes is
going to propel you into a better
you know put you in a better position to
succeed in life it just seems like if
that's what you want to do just get into
it yeah learn on the go don't take out
debt to learn how to act right don't
take out debt
right unless someone's paying for your
college yeah that's the thing like if
unless you're well that was like my
ex-girlfriend's thing i hate to put out
her your business
she had a wealthy family so they kind of
took care of her and all that she mean
she now has this restaurant successful
restaurant but yeah thing is there's a
lot also a lot of value in that in that
major like they're like i learned with
her there was a lot of stuff to learn
from the arts it's just not a lot of roi
right but there's a whole ton of like
life experience and end of the day
that's why you're going to college is
for the roi on the investment for the
education i went to florida state okay i
went i was a general communications
major i can think i graduated
you know 18 years ago
i could think
of maybe three classes that i remember
taking one of them happened to be
listening
but for connor listening to the other
classes
for college it's not so much about
unless you know you want to be a doctor
you know you want to be a lawyer you
know you want to be an engineer you know
that you have that you want to go down a
career path where you need this
schooling and you need the specialty and
you need the certifications i get it but
if you don't know what you're doing
right yeah there may be some better
options for you i.e trade schools i.e
technical schools right maybe you go to
a coding school maybe you go to a
community college you're talking about
community college being free maybe you
enter the workforce understand what you
don't want to do or what you want to do
and double down on that trade schools i
mean plumbers technicians
carpenters engineers these guys make
loot and they don't gotta dig themselves
into college debt it's a big deal gotta
dig themselves and it's hard label it
hard labor yeah
dude yeah you get the money and um
that's how we really first you get the
money first you get the money then you
get the power then you get then you get
the respect that's how it works chico
you said it but you never get the money
then you don't get the power then you
get no respect it's in the ice chicken
surprise you just said it right exactly
those are for the people out there
anyway
thank you for i would like to know
people out there thumbs up college
thumbs down college i don't know i'm not
saying don't go to college i'm saying
there is a difference between college
and education i've definitely learned
more
after college real life experience on
the job training negotiations sales all
that than what i've learned in college
make no freaking mistake about it
college is good for certain things
you know social social situations right
understanding who to befriend who not to
be a friend just contacts right there's
like there's the um
you know
learning side of things and then there's
the emotional social component of it all
okay but at the end of the day
what you need to understand and it's so
hard to do especially when you're 17 18
how the hell do you look in the future
but as best as you can do a cost-benefit
analysis of what
the risk and reward of going to college
what's the roi in your major how much
student loans am i taking out how much
am i gonna how long is it gonna take me
to pay back my student loans on average
it takes people 18 to 20 years to pay
off their student loans how much
interest am i paying what the is
interest what's the interest rate
understood like all this stuff you need
to understand anyway i'm not saying
don't go to college i'm just saying
before you go to college do the math
do the math now if you're one of these
um
one of these people that are going to
these bottom five majors
just know that if you're like i've
always wanted to go to college and i've
always wanted to be in theater cool god
bless you go for it you do know you're
gonna make on average thirty five
thousand dollars a year and then return
on your investments you know
i didn't know that well now you do
okay anyway
colleges are getting so much more
expensive i just
a part of me appreciates college i get
it but part of me thinks college is a
scam
it is
a lot of it is scam i said it
yeah i kind of agree okay
yeah podcast uh not podcasts college
isn't obviously as valuable now anymore
like back in the day was because no one
could afford to go to college
yeah and so yeah go to college you'll be
like one out of the ten people out there
that does have a degree yeah so then it
was valuable but now everyone has a
great
degree so it doesn't make a difference
anymore dude you can just put on your
resume i have a degree what are they
going to do and i love that these big
tech companies
um are hiring people without degrees
right yeah that's awesome big tech
companies out there tesla's coming out
there saying you don't need a degree
right yeah microsoft ibm facebook we'll
get into facebook in a second what the
hell happened with facebook oh boy right
who's the poster boy for dropping out of
college and starting a business does
zuck himself your boy zuck
your boy's son your boy's dog look at
him mark zuckerberg anyway so he dropped
out of college started facebook let's
just get into this story can we make the
argument that if it weren't for college
and him trying to connect everyone at
that college he would have made facebook
damn you just you just zinged me i'm out
of here anyway
anyway if you had an opportunity to go
to harvard you go to harvard
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken